the actor Stephen Tomkinson has been
found not guilty of assaulting a man
outside his home the 57 year old a star
of DCI Banks he was accused of punching
a man who was drunkenly making noises
outside the actor's home in the early
hours of May the 30th in 2021 that's two
years ago and we obviously got a huge
amount of detail in during the trial
jurors heard that the two men had been
drinking since midnight that bank
holiday Sunday they were told that the
the two men had gone to the beach before
passing Stephen tomkinson's home in
Whitley Bay in north tyneside on the
walk back and jurors heard as well that
the actor who was living with his
partner and her seven-year-old son at
the time said he heard some strange
noises went out to challenge the two who
were described by him as heavily
intoxicated and he said he called 999
after seeing the pair are trying to
stand up and fall several times while
drinking from a bottle of jagermaster
and also Meister rather and also during
the trial he said that while he was
waiting to be connected he went outside
and told the pair that he was calling
the police and so Stephen Tomkinson also
told the court that the two men took
great objection to him complaining and
had started to move towards him and
during the trial his evidence was that
he'd put his hand out to stop Mr pool
coming any further that was one of the
two men outside his house and made
contact with his face but he told jurors
it wasn't enough to knock a sober man
off his feet and clearly jurors agreed
with Stephen Tomkinson in this case and
he has been found not guilty at New
Castle Crown Court of inflicting
Grievous bodily harm so let's get some
more details now outside the court is uh
our correspondent Katarina vitotsi so
Katarina what more can you tell us
well in the end excuse me in the end
Anna this was a unanimous decision by
the jury who spent only about two hours
deliberating sent out shortly after
three o'clock yesterday afternoon uh as
I say a unanimous not guilty verdict
from them they believed the defense's
argument that the actor Stephen
Tomkinson did little more than put his
hand out in self-defense and then that
Cole pull one of the two men who had
been outside his house drunk they
admitted that they were had fallen over
and and hit his head on the pavement as
a result of that act the prosecution
throughout had claimed that the actor in
there in his interaction with the two
drunk men outside his house may last
year simply snapped they say that he he
slapped and punched Mr pool and that is
what led to him falling over the defense
saying that that simply wasn't the case
and the jury here as I say taking just
about two hours or so to come to that
not guilty verdict on the charge of
Grievous bodily harm now the actor who
was 57 had been at home at the time with
his partner and and their and his and
her child their seven-year-old child and
the actor said uh in the course of uh
this trial that he simply wouldn't have
acted in an aggressive way because of
the nature of his celebrity he said why
would I risk all that I have worked hard
for in in a moment of Madness at the
defense the jury agreeing with that
versions of events here at Newcastle
Crown Court unanimously finding Stephen
tompkinson the actor known for well
those of a certain vintage will remember
him from programs such as balika's Angel
but more recently things like DCI Banks
and found not guilty here today of that
charge of Grievous bodily harm